That's… that's a dinosaur, isn't it?
Isn't it a T-Rex?
The dynamite must have exposed it.
Salt rock is a good preserver,
but it's been preserved
in unbelievably excellent condition.
And that's a human.
Yeah, there's no doubt about that.
But how can this be explained?
Does it even matter?
It's just like it looks.
Were humans even around in that era?
Does that even matter?
Clearly, this human lived then.
It looks like he's attacking the T-Rex.
But
considering its size,
that's just not possible.
It's likely this is his intense reaction
to being attacked.
Even if that's true,
he's got a heck of a lot of guts.
What do we do now?
This is an incredible find.
First, we'll contact HQ.